make a little subheading underneath
where you just did this working and that
subheading is a new word or a word maybe
some of you have heard of but most of
you probably wouldn't which is quantiles
what our quantiles okay so even if
you've never been introduced this word
before you actually know exactly what
they are we just never said it and we
even were mentioning it earlier on when
we have a look at our concepts before
and we were talking about quartiles do
you remember those we would say the
medians the second quartile the idea of
quartile is it's a score that divides or
two set of scores actually that divide
you up into four equal chunks hence what
right court for caught up okay so
quartiles are those three scores and we
would call them q1 q2 and q3 and these
three scores if you have a set of scores
right q1 q2 and q3 break you won't put
into four equal chunks that makes sense
but quartiles are not the only kind of
way to divide up maybe you want more
detail than dividing into fours so if
for example you took this same thing and
divided into one two three or four five
six seven eight nine ten groups you
really call them quartiles anymore
there's ten of them so we call them
deciles very good so deciles what if you
wanted even more detail you're like I
want to divide into a hundred equal
sections
you call them percentiles and of course
we're quite familiar with these guys
because of everyone's favorite
percentile the eight are right so we've
talked about this before okay so the
whole idea is we can divide up our
distribution into whatever kinds of
chunks we want yeah
what does percent mean what does percent
mean no seriously what doesn't mean kind
of a hundred yeah so this is dividing
into 100 chunks
did someone sharpen it okay all right so
how do we use what we've just developed
I'll just wait all Serene's ready you
good sure double sure
just wanted to be certain how do we use
this EDF to work out this stuff here
okay just have a look at the first one
for me have a look at the first one
you've got a new probability density
function you can take in those details
in fact you've already got them so you
might as well do the working on the
piece of paper that we've supplied how
do we use the CDF to find out say for
example the the median that's the first
one that's being asked for right I'm
gonna think about this we already know
how to find medians how do we use the
language of the CDF to help us here what
are you thinking sure oh yeah sure ah
we'll come to that in a minute we'll
come to that for now don't don't lose
close with me here right for Part A if
we're searching for a median okay the
median we know divides you in half it
divides the scores in half so that means
if we start from the bottom and go all
the way up to the median what should be
where you know this what's the
probability of all this stuff that we've
already passed it's 0.5 1/2 right so
therefore there is some value of x right
the median such that if you find that
you should equal 1/2 right because the
definition of the cumulative
distribution function is all the
probabilities up unto your particular
value right so that's the medium you can
go ahead and you can work that out
what about Part B it says the third
quartile so the third quartile right
what we would do is we would say of your
cumulative distribution function the
third quartile is this guy here right
you start you end here's your third
quartile one two three
so how much of the probability should be
covered over here this is 3/4 of the
score so it's 3/4 of your probability so
therefore f of X for this will be 3 over
4 or 0.75 right you're gonna start to
see where this is going right the 67th
percentile for the 67th percentile once
you know what the CDF is then it's going
to be well up to an including 67%
of your score so to be 67 over 100 and
then you're going to get a value like
there will be some expression for X over
here your f of X and then it'll equal
that and you'll have to solve for X does
that make sense or they supply
particular arm pronumerals for you to
use and one more because I think they
asked for desu ours right the eighth
disel yeah so because we're divided into
tenths right this is the eighth one
along so therefore I want to solve for
it being equal to 8 over 10 well this is
the way you're going to get there I
don't know what X is for any of these
you're going to find out what particular
values of X would give you these
particular fractions okay I don't know
what the f of X capital f of X is so
you're gonna have to find that out and
then use it to solve these equations
that make sense